[موسيقى]
منذ البدايه شكلت الحرب في اوكرانيا
امتحانا صعبا لدول حلف الناتو صحيح قدم
الدول النيتو مساعدات عسكريه كبيره
لاوكرانيا هذه المساعدات مكنتها من الصمود
امام روسيا لكن هذه الحرب الان باتت تشكل
اختبارا جادا لوحده مواقف هذه الدول هذا
في ظل التباينات الاخيره حول شكل الدعم
العسكري المسموح به للاوكرانيين وكذلك
ايضا مدى استعداد دول الحلفة لمواجهه
تابعات مساعداته المستمره لاوكرانيا او
حتى امكانيه التصعيد العسكريه مع موسكو
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا المستشار السابق
لقياده حلف النيتو في الولايات المتحده
وايضا الباحث في الشؤون العسكريه الدكتور
موريزيووجيري اولا الدكتور مريزيو اهلا بك
معنا في عسكريتانيا يعني الان عام على
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه لكن بعد كل هذه
الفتره كيف تقيم تعاطي الدول الاوروبيه مع
الموقف والحرب ما بين روسيا واوكرانيا حتى
هذه اللحظه
شكرا لاستضافه في برنامجكم كما شاهدنا
مؤخرا ومع قرار المانيا مؤخرا بارسال
دبابات اليوبارت عقب الخطوه الامريكيه
بارسال دبابات حلفونات الان اقوى من اي
وقت مضى اثر الطلب الذي تقدمت به اوكرانيا
لمساعدتها في تحرير اراضيها من المحتل
الامبريالي الروسي واعتداءاته وعلينا ان
نلاحظ ان هذه هي الحرب الاولى لقوه
النوويه في التاريخ البشريه بالتالي فان
الناتو لا يدافع عن اوكرانيا بل يدافع عن
العالم كله في وجه هذه القوه الامبرياليه
التي تذكرنا بعهد النازيه حين سعى هتلر
لبناء المانيا العظمى من خلال ضم الاقليات
الالمانيه في انحاء البلاد ويبدو بوتين
وكانه يحذو حذوه بضم الاقليه الروسيه في
دول الجوار وقال بصريح العباره ان هدفه
قوات الناتو الى الوضع الذي كانت عليه قبل
1997 اي عندما لم يكن في تحالف الناتو دول
من شرقي اوروبا اي دول الاتفاق وارسو
وفكرته هي بناء روسيا حديثه من خلال الغزو
والاستيلاء على اراضي دول المجاوره مثل
جورجيا في 2008 ثم اوكرانيا 2014 واخيرا
الغزو الشامل لاوكرانيا العام الماضي وبعد
عام من الحرب نرى ان اوكرانيا تصرفت بشكل
جيد وبشجاعه وبتحضير جيد كما كان رد
الناتو جيدا من خلال وحده اعضائه وبصلاحيه
واضحه وهي حمايه اراضي دول الحلف ودعم
شركائه اذ علينا ان نتذكر انه منذ
1994 اصبحت اوكرانيا وغيرها من دول
الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق شركاء للناتو كما
هو الحال بالنسبه لشركاء الناتو في
المتوسط وفي الخليج ونحن ندعم جميع
شركائنا بالتدريب والمناورات العسكريه
اين كيف تمكنت اوكرانيا بقوه من الصمود
امام هذا العدوان ومؤخرا طلبت اوكرانيا
المزيد من السلاح وخاصه السلاح الثقيله
مثل المدرعات وكذلك الدفاعات الجويه وارسل
الناتو في الشهرين الاخيرين دفعه جويه
لاوكرانيا وحاليا تحاول كل من ايطاليا
وفرنسا ارسال دفاعات جويه وانظمتها
لاوكرانيا وكذلك لاستعاده الاراضي من
الاحتلال الروسي طلبت اوكرانيا بالحصول
على دبابات ومركبات مدرعه متقدمه ووافقت
المانيا مؤخرا على ان ترسل دول اوروبيه
مختلفه دبابات لاوكرانيا من المانيا لان
المانيا هي الدوله المصنعه لهذه الدبابات
لذلك نحتاج الى اذن اعاده تصدير من
المانيا وقامت الولايات المتحده بخطوه
رياضيه بارسال دبابه لاوكرانيا املين بهذا
ان تتمكن القوات الاوكرانيه من استعاده
اراضيها من الاحتلال الروسي وهذه الملامح
التي تتحدث عنها دكتور موريزو هل تعتقد
بان هذه الملامح لن تقتصر خلال المرحله
المقبله على الدفاع من قبل الاوكرانيين
ربما يقوم الجيش الاوكراني خلال المرحله
القادمه بعمليات هجوميه ضد الجيش الروسي
في الشرق او في الجنوب في دومباس على سبيل
المثال
نعم نحن نرى هذه الحرب على انها الاولى
لهذا الجيل الخامس بمعنى استخدام الاسلحه
والانظمه التكنولوجيه المتقدمه وقد كانت
المسيرات التي وصلت من احدى دول الناتو
وهي تركيا مفيده جدا لاوكرانيا لكن في
نهايه الامر عندما تكون هناك قوه احتلال
تسيطر على اراضيك عندها يتسنى عليك
استعاده الاراضي بعمليه عسكريه بريه اي
بالدبابات والمركبات المدرعه وكان من
الطبيعي ان تطالب اوكرانيا في هذه الحاله
بالحصول على دبابات ولتحرير الاراضي انت
بحاجه الى قوه مشاه مسلحه ما يعني ارسال
المزيد من السلاح والذخيره لاوكرانيا
وربما ايضا قوه جويه لان القوه الجويه
بوسعها تقديم التغطيه والدعم للمشاه في
معارك تحرير الاراضي لكن الولايات المتحده
قالت انها ليست مستعده لذلك الدعم الجوي
بعد وان الامر يع اوكرانيا في ان تحدد
الاسلوب والاستراتيجيه والعمليات التي
ستعتمدها لتحرير اراضيها سنرى ما هي
المطالب التاليه القادمه من اوكرانيا لكن
من المؤكد ان دول الناتو متحده ومتفقه
بشان دعمها لاوكرانيا الدكتور موريزيو
لنكن اكثر واقعيه هل ستقبل دوله نوويه
بالهزيمه خاصه بانه الاختيارات المطروحه
الان على طاوله الرئيس الروسي وعلى طاوله
الكريم ليست خيارات كثيره
هي ان عقيده جرانكو هي ضم الاقليه الروسيه
في المنطقه الى روسيا وكانت قد تمت
استضافه جرانكو مؤخرا في برنامج تلفزيوني
قال فيه انه ينصح بوتين بالقسوه وعدم
التهاون لكن هذا هو الاسلوب الذي اعتمده
بوتين منذ البدايه وربما قبل ذلك عندما
احتل القرم وجورجيا لذلك فانه هجومه
الوحشيه معروف وهو لن يغير اسلوبه اسلوب
والطغيان والعدوان لاحتلال دول مستقله ذات
سياده هذا ما قام به في الماضي وان استمر
في هذا النظام فانه سيواصل استهداف دول
اخرى مثل دول البلطيق التي فيها اقليه
روسيه وبالتالي يعتبرها اراضيه تابعه له
لكن لا اعتقد انه سيصل الى ذلك الحد لان
اوكرانيا وبمساعده الناتو ستتمكن مع نهايه
العام الذي سيكون العام الثاني لهذه الحرب
ستتمكن من اخراج القوات الروسيه وسيرى
بوتين وبيطانته والعسكريه كوزير الدفاع
ورئيس قوه فاجنر انه لا يستطيع الصمود
امام دوله تحارب من اجل الحفاظ على
استقلالها وعندها ستتراجع القوه الروسيه
وستبدا حينها المفاوضات